hey this is presh talwalkar a cat is
hiding in one of five boxes that are
lined up in a row the boxes are numbered
one to five
each night the cat hides in an adjacent
box exactly one number away
each morning you can open a single box
to try to find the cat
can you win this game of hide and seek
what is your strategy for finding the
cat
here's a bonus problem what if there are
n boxes in a row
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
i'm first going to go over some
strategies which won't work
the first thing you should not do is
search randomly and hope to find the cat
let's imagine on the first day you
search box 3.
unknown to you the cat is in box 2.
now let's imagine the next day you
search box 2 and unknown to you the cat
moves to box three
if you search haphazardly you might keep
missing and never find the cat
so you should not just search randomly
another thing you should not do is you
should not just simply keep opening the
same box
let's imagine the first day you check
box two
unknown to you the cat is in box four
now imagine you keep checking box two
every single day
well it could be that the cat is looping
between boxes 3 and 4
so you will never check a box where the
cat actually is
so if you keep checking the same box you
might also never find the cat
so you might wonder is it possible that
you will ever find the cat
the answer is yes
we can imagine a simpler case of three
boxes
the cat could start in any of the three
boxes
now let's suppose you check box two
because it's in the middle
if you do find the cat you win
otherwise you know the cat must have
been in an odd numbered box one or three
well at night you know that the cat is
going to move one box
so from either case the cat is going to
have to move to box two
on the next day you can therefore check
box two and you will find the cat
so this simple case suggests
a pattern since the cat alternates
between even and odd numbered boxes we
should split up the cases between the
cat being in an even and an odd numbered
box
so let's return to the five boxes case
the cat could start in any of the five
boxes
but let's consider that the cat is in an
even numbered box that would be box two
or box four
on the first day we can check one of the
boxes let's check box two
if you do find the cat you win
otherwise that means the cat must have
been in box four
now that cat will move one box to either
box three or box five
so the next day you check box three
if you do find the cat you win
otherwise you know the cat must have
been in box five
and now the cat is going to move one box
and it's going to end up in box four
so on the third day you can check box
four and you are going to find the cat
for sure
so this strategy works at the cats
started in an even numbered box two or
four
but what if the cat started in an odd
numbered box 1 3 or 5.
well let's see what happens after we
check for 3 days
so we have the cat starting in an odd
numbered
box the cat moves one box at night
so it's going to be in two or four the
next day
from there it's going to move one box
and then it's going to move one more box
so that means on the start of the fourth
day the cat is going to be in box two or
four
in other words on the fourth day the cat
will be in an even numbered box
so now we need to catch a cat that's in
an even numbered box
so our problem reduces to case one that
the cat is in an even numbered box
and now
the problem has reduced to one that
we've already solved to catch the cat we
can now check box 2 then box 3 and then
box 4.
so the whole trick is that we needed to
guess an even numbered box when the cat
is in an even numbered box this makes
the difference between our guess and the
cat's box an even number every single
day so we never miss the cat by just one
box
alternately we could have guessed an odd
numbered box when the cat is in in an
odd numbered box
this also makes a difference between our
guests and the cats box an even number
every single day
remember this when we go to the four box
case which will be much later in the
video
so to summarize
we can solve this problem by first
checking box two then box three and then
box four
this will catch a cat that started in an
even numbered box on day one
we then can repeat this because
this will catch a cat that started in an
odd numbered box which will then be in
an even numbered box by day four
now there are a couple things i want to
mention first there are equivalent
solutions for an odd number of boxes
so the strategy 234 will catch a cat
that starts in an even box on day one
but there's another way you could have
actually done it from the other end you
could have done box four then three then
two
this will also catch a cat that started
in an even numbered box on day one
one of the ways that you can understand
this is that you could imagine the
numbers being in the exact opposite
order
two three four is like catching a cat
with the numbering going from left to
right and four three two is like
catching the same cats if the numbering
goes from right to left so they're
equivalent by the symmetry of the boxes
in the line
so because there are equivalent
solutions for catching a cat in an even
numbered box there are actually four
different ways that we could catch this
cat
we could repeat two three four
we could also do two three four then
four three two we could do four three
two then two three four or we could
repeat four three two
so the solution i'm going to illustrate
in the next version is 234 and then 432
so we search one way and then we reverse
the order
this will also be useful when we
consider an even number of boxes
so first let me illustrate this in a
grid
we have five boxes that we're going to
check over several days
so in this grid i'm going to mark a gray
rectangle for possible boxes that the
cat could be in
on the first day the cat could be in any
of the five boxes
i'm then going to use a blue rectangle
to mean the box you check on that day so
the first day you check box 2.
i will then mark a black rectangle to
mean boxes the cat cannot possibly be
we're deducing this by the process of
elimination
so on the first day you check box two if
you find the cat you win
if not that means the next day you know
the cat cannot be in box one because if
the cat was not in box two on the first
day
there's no way it could have moved to
box one it can only get to box one from
box two the night before
so we know that on the second day the
cat cannot be in the first box but it
could be in any of the other boxes
so on the next day we check box three
if we find the cat we win
otherwise
we know that the cat was not in boxes
one or three so that would mean the next
day it could not be in box two
it could be in any of the other boxes
we then check box
four this will catch a cat that started
in an even numbered box on the first day
if we did not catch the cat by now
we know that on the third day the cat is
not in box two and it's not in box four
so it could not be in an odd numbered
box the next day we can eliminate boxes
1 3 and 5.
this is also equivalently saying that
the cat has to be in an even numbered
box on the fourth day
so now we check one of these boxes we
check box four
if we find the cat we win otherwise
since the cat was not in box four
that means it could not be in any of the
even numbered boxes because it's not in
any of the odd number boxes and it can't
be in box five because the only way i
could have gone to box five is to have
been in box four on the day before
so we now only have two possible places
that the cat could be it could be in box
one or box three
we now check box three if we find the
cat we win otherwise we know it's not in
any box except for box one
so the cat's gonna have to move one box
and on the final day there's only one
possibility it has to be in box two
so this is the only possible place the
cat could be so we check that box and
we're going to win for sure
so now let's consider a different case
where the total number of boxes is an
even number
let's consider that there are four boxes
and the cat could be in any of the four
boxes
we'll split up the search into two
different cases let's suppose the cat
starts in an even numbered box that
would be box two or box four
we might as well search one of these
boxes so we'll get started by searching
box two
if the cat is there we win
otherwise we would deduce the cat must
have been in box four
the cat is going to move one box and
that means it's gonna have to move to
box three
therefore on the next day we can search
box three and we're going to win
so we're going to catch the cat using
the strategy if the cat started in an
even numbered box
but what if the cat started in an odd
numbered box
this case is going to be slightly
different the reason is that the cat is
still going to be in an odd numbered box
on the third day
let's see why suppose on the first day
the cat started in an odd numbered box
overnight it moves one box
and then it's going to move one more box
so on the third day the cat is still in
an odd numbered box so we're going to
have to catch a cat that is in an odd
numbered box
to do that we might as well search one
of the boxes
so in this case we're going to search
box three
we're going to do our search in reverse
we did two three now we're gonna do
three two so we start up by searching
box three if the cat is there we win
otherwise we can deduce the cat must
have been in box one
so overnight the cat is gonna move one
box it's gonna have to move to box two
so we're then going to search box two
and we're going to catch the cat for
sure
so notice that this search was going to
be 2 3 and then the reverse search of 3
2.
so this brings us to the general way of
how you can catch a cat
in any number of boxes where n is even
or odd
in the first search you check the boxes
going from 2 to n minus 1
this will catch a cat that started in an
even numbered box on the first day
in the next search you do the boxes in
exactly the reverse order
this will catch a cat that started in an
odd numbered box on the first day
for completeness you can also reverse
steps 1 and 2
and if n is odd you can also win by
doing two searches of step one or two
searches of step two
so that describes some of the ways that
you can catch the cat
where n is either even or odd and you
will catch the cat for sure
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description